hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world what
I do have a problem with is being lied
about and then putting that out there
that's true frankly we have to stop
illegal immigration what we are going
through in this country is not simply an
economic downturn we are living through
a massive economic transformation trust
terror immigration and economy are these
what you are worried about
are you suffering debate fatigue has a
Republican leader emerged following this
week's debate in Wisconsin in one year
the polls will open but what will be the
topics you'll be voting on Alastair
Campbell is with us he's Tony Blair's
former director of communications and
strategy our two regulars are in the
studio with me hello to Geoffrey
Robinson as usual on the left and the
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams on the right of your picture
gentlemen it's great to have you with us
terrific being here in London now are
you getting debate fatigue yeah of
course I've had it since the beginning I
mean as long as Donald Trump is in there
it's amusing and it's show business if
he ever leaves I would watch reruns of
law and order long before I would watch
these clowns because they really got
nothing to say they they're making a
joke of the political process and none
of them are electable why would I care
but that's the process wherein Armstrong
isn't it that's the system you guys have
got well it's a little different from
for me I'm for full disclosure I'm dr.
Carson's business manager and advise a
longtime friend and so as someone who
has worked with him in preparation for
the debates and have watched all the
debates I actually thought that last
night's debate was full of substance it
was clearly the best debate to put
together where they really got a chance
to talk about the issues and no I have
no debate 40 because I understand the
importance of the next presidential
election and the person at the people
with the people choose and so there's
much at stake for our nation lots to
talk about in the next few minutes let's
bring in Alastair Campbell who's just
returned from America he's witnessed
electioneering there firsthand he was
there promoting his book winners and how
they succeed which i guess is
appropriate during the presidential
election campaign Alastair good to have
you with us today now what about this
debate process do you think it's one
that we should do more of in the UK no I
think that the American system stems
from a time when candidates had to
travel thousands and thousands of miles
and go to every state and but now that
you've got mass communication and they
can travel fairly easily I think the
American presidential campaign is way
way way too long
I do think these debates have been
interesting but I think that the more
they get narrowed down the better they
will they will become I mean I was as
you say I was in the States for a while
and and I think for an outsider going in
it is it's baffling to watch the debate
because you have a sense of to my mind
politicians and in the case of Trump
Carson and Fiorina non politicians that
were who are trying to use that to their
advantage you have the the candidates
kind of vying with each other to appeal
to a to a party base but the more that
they do that to my mind the more
unelectable they make themselves for the
general public and I think the more they
have to do these debates the more they
have to get noticed that it's often the
crazy of the things that they have to
say to feel that they can touch this
base then I think that the more
difficult it becomes to imagine them as
presidents I mean I met friend of what i
was doing one interview about my book at
CBS and dr. Carson was there and you
know I thought he was a perfectly nice
guy but I couldn't imagine him as a
president of the United States of
America I can't imagine Donald Trump as
the president of United States of
America now unless I'm missing something
then I guess I my senses that those two
will fade and there are my own bet is
that Rubio is going to emerge but I just
what what's missing in them in this in
this context of being a winner what's
missing from what their personality or
their politics I think with trumpets
kind of fairly obvious I I think they're
you know Jeffrey saying that you know
it's for like while he's there it's like
showbiz it's like entertainment and even
though in a way the media and politics
have made politics almost at times the
media coverage is almost feels like it
is part of the entertainment industry
deep down I think that people know that
it's not and therefore I think that he
just to me and I think to most Europeans
looking in on this debate just people
find it baffling that he's even there
doing as well as years I think with dr.
Carson and with Trump I think that they
to my mind that they the reason why a
Rubio is coming over to me as a more
winning and more attractive candidate is
he does seem to have a message about the
future I feel with the others that
they're talking all the time about the
past even make America great again is
kind of saying we've lost our past and I
think that all elections are about
tomorrow yes you get your life torn to
bits as dr. Carson is fine at the moment
you get everything you've ever said
analyzed and torn to bits but it's
always about the future and that's why I
think that the people who will most be
enjoying watching these Republican
debates I I suspected the Democrats
Armstrong mr. Carson dr. Carson is
having his life torn to shreds isn't he
with all these things about West Point
frenzy well not at all their lives that
have been told which had been refuted
whether its political or the wall street
journal even NBC News did a report
refueling the lies that have been told
and to mr. Alistair I want to
congratulate him on write his book and I
wish him well but to me he's an outsider
he cannot begin to understand what's
going on in American politics and he
himself as establishment person he
probably knows many of these leaders
that are running vying for the office of
President and he has relationships and
he's like many Americans are established
and establishment media they don't
understand why people would look to
someone like mr. Trump and mr. Carson
and they keep wondering what an American
people will come to their good senses
and unlike and start giving energy and
support to one of these establishment
candidates but I like to tell mr.
alastair that's not going to happen
America is an uprising it's in a
revolution it does not want the
establishment it was something different
they want to repudiate those system
because it has not worked for them and
even if as Jeffrey and I sit here today
none of us can tell you who actually
will win the White House in 2016 as
that's the kind of error we find
ourselves in yes I can yes I can Hillary
Clinton I mean there's there's no doubt
about this because the Republicans don't
have a single viable candidate who could
get the nomination now the one candidate
wants somebody would impose somebody
will one of the clowns but one of the
the one one of the few candidates who
actually could be seen as a president is
John Kasich the governor from Ohio Jeb
Bush perhaps but Bush we're not going to
elect a third Bush the thing with the
Carson
champagne is the wheels are coming off
the clown car you know these are not
lies about him Robinson's law when a
politician complains about the media you
know he's guilty absolutely
unequivocably the fact is his his memory
is faulty about all sorts of things he's
invented in his biography he can't run
on a political record he's running on
his autobiography which is filled with
falsifications and outright lies he
invented a course at Yale that never
happened and then he blames the media
and he blamed his ghostwriter let me
tell you something that somebody was
written three best-selling as told tues
there is no possibility whatsoever that
his ghostwriter inserted something that
he didn't know about he had at least six
chances and asked Alistair because he's
just gone through the book process how
many times you get to ring over and over
he had six chances to take that out he
left it in because he knew he was lying
it helped the he can address that but
I'd also wanted to address the Jefferies
other theory Alastair which is if a
politician or navy a politician's
assistant starts complaining about the
media they're both guilty what do you
think about that theory no I don't buy
that I don't you can unequivocally state
that I think there are some work because
he's a politician no but I've also got a
lot of experience of media saying things
that are wrong and eventually accept
that they're wrong but I think that on
the point look I'm strong is right that
I'm an outsider but I think sometimes
it's useful to have Outsiders eyes to
come in and look at the process because
I'll tell you something else that I
found really quite disturbing about the
the election and that is the extent to
which is it appears so parochial and
when they do talk about foreign policy
it's like just embarrassing the level of
the debate I mean Trump goes on about
putting up walls and dr. Carson talks
about we should have armed the Jews with
guns and then there wouldn't have been a
Holocaust and they all have these very
simplistic analyses of Vladimir Putin or
Syria whatever it might be and so it's
important that he understands that
outsiders are entitled to viewing this
because the election the president
United States matters to all of us and
therefore I think that something like me
who has gone through lots of elections
and has done through lots of campaigns
both winning and losing but has learnt a
lot on the way
there are certain principles of winning
campaigns that you know you can look at
and even apply and I just feel like
you're right i don't know i could be
wrong none of us know but i think that
you wear armstrong is right is and we
saw this with the election of jeremy
corbyn is leader the late partying in
the UK that there is a desire amongst
the public for something different
there's a desire amongst the public
actually kick politicians but at the
same time people aren't stupid they know
ultimately they're going to choose the
person who's going to sit down on a
table opposite Vladimir Putin opposite
Netanyahu is going to have to deal with
the Middle East is gonna have to deal
with Isis and some of the stuff that
these guys come up with is so simplistic
I've got to tell you it's embarrassing
I'm strong let me ask you to address
that the American people are not stupid
they understand exactly what you say and
just like Alastair who may have met dr.
Carson a green room it's unfair for him
to speak to him four minutes and come to
a conclusion without having a thoroughly
vetted conversation I wouldn't want to
make that judgment about Tony McLaren
when he was writing for Prime Minister's
it would be unfair on asked his point
about the sort of naivety or the lack of
experience isn't that a valid criticism
that any one of these novice candidates
you know within weeks could be facing
President Putin across a negotiating
table but Martin they do that the beauty
of this is that you surround yourself
with people who have the expertise who
have been in those positions and dr.
Carson has always talked about
surrounding himself with the best
counselors even Alistair and Jeffrey no
matter how bright how gifted they are in
their field there are things they can
learn in their field every day from
others at the bottom line is dr. Carson
mr. Trump have the potential to get to
the point because they're still in the
infancy of this but when they get to the
point and begin to grow and understand
the complexity of these issues no they
don't have a legislative record I think
given what other like that officials
have given us over the last 20 years I
think the American people are saying
what do we stand to lose ok we're going
to hold the conversation there Jeffrey
you're going to come right I need to
tell you what we stand to lose in just a
couple of moments
reminder you can catch up with the Sky
News debate on Apple TV Roku and catch
up and of course at Sky News com / us so
we were talking about credibility
Jeffrey and whether a novice can do the
job of president I will tell you a story
in 1991 of golf 1 91 and 92 when Saddam
Hussein burned the oil fields in Kuwait
they hired one of those guys and I
forget if it was boots and coots or red
Adair one of the guys who puts out oil
fires and he went to put out all these
humongous oil fires in Kuwait and Time
magazine stumbled across the fact that
he personally was earning a million
dollars a day for his services he
personally not the company him putting
in his pocket a million bucks a day so
they went to boots and coots are red
Adair with pike these Cowboys great
characters and said is it true that
you're earning a million dollars a day
he said that's right and they said isn't
that expensive he says if you all think
that's expensive try hiring an amateur
America will not hire an ammeter for
president the United States let's bring
in Alastair Campbell again Alastair I
mean tree because you use a lot of
extrapolation into sport don't you in
your winners book and make comparisons
of fact between sports people and
successful sports people and successful
politicians how do you explain the fact
that success can be so ephemeral I mean
Austin Vegas a hero one minute he has a
great bad run of form Mourinho to use
the soccer analogy here in the UK at the
moment is having a disastrous season and
yet he was your hero when you
interviewed him for the book heroes
heroes they said but certainly is a
winner he's won in the top level in four
different countries but here's as you
say going through a very bad batch and I
think that one of the reasons why i do
think i agree with Geoffrey I think
Hillary Clinton will emerge as the
winner I think resilience is an
incredibly important quality in a
campaigner and Hillary's learnt from
defeat one of my favorite quotes in the
book is from an Irishman is an athletics
coach in Kenya called column O'Connell
and he says the winner is the loser who
evaluates defeat properly and I think
Hillary has learned from defeat I don't
think it's funny so interesting to watch
Donald Trump and the way I think he went
into this campaign not expected to do as
well as he's done he's having to go
through a different sort of adaptation
you do have to adapt as you go but the
thing about you know when we talk about
the getting the best people around you
that's about team ship is about team
building and that's important in sport
as it importers in politics I mean there
are parallels but there are also
differences the biggest difference is
that sport is very much that the results
are fairly clear cut you know you don't
have a debate and then you have a poll
about who won you have a match and the
person who scores the most points wins
and it's much easier to work out but I
think where where politics is really
really important is you have to have a
really really hard and enduring strategy
and again I don't sense that I think
these guys are very they feel very
tactical to me and I'm songs right that
it's unfair of me to kind of make a
general judgment about a brief meeting
but it's not you know it's not the only
thing that may leads me to make a
judgment I mean I watch these guys
performing and I read what they say and
I just have a sense that there he's
right that I could be wrong but my sense
is that they are dominant in what you
might call the entertainment phase of
this I think when it gets down to the
business end I think it will chain you
just just a thought though about the old
rubric that all politicians lives end in
failure so the success you've quantified
in this book does it desert everyone in
time is it finite no because if you look
at mean I've just been walking across
Parliament Square and there's a
wonderful statue of Abraham Lincoln
there Abraham Lincoln's reputation today
is probably greater than any time even
when he was in office and I think
likewise if you think of something like
Muhammad Ali Muhammad Ali lost fights
but you know people think of him as a as
a hero in all sorts of different ways so
so actually no I think with time
reputation changes and it develops and
when you're talking about big historical
figures bein sport or business or or
politics that if you like the gay the
the reputation never stops developing
and it can
for good or for bad Alastair Campbell
thanks very much Jeffrey yeah yeah I
agree to some extent it helps and I hate
to say this but it helps to be
assassinated Kennedy on to die young
Elvis Maryland the reputation is frozen
in time so they can't become losers with
age the fact is the last time America
hired an amateur is president was Dwight
Eisenhower hmm but he won World War two
I mean he had some real street cred ben
Carson is not Dwight Eisenhower and of I
rest my case but yet but yet you off
well he's not a Eisenhower or in that
league yet no do you never want to be in
that league welcomes happen if he says
comes on television and says I've never
held elected office and neither had any
of the founding fathers who signed the
Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence dead wrong they'd all held
elective office I mean he comes up with
these completely idiotic thing the
pyramids were were made to store grain
completely denies 5,000 years of
Egyptology I mean he says these things
as if they're fact and when you look at
them you realize he doesn't know what
he's talking about and when you accuse
him of that or making stuff up like he
did with his course at Yale he said
blames the media you're taking me out of
context it was my ghostwriter you've got
me wrong I can't stand it now blaming
the media is a good tact for the
Republicans and they're always gets an
applause line but the fact is they're
still wrong and when you blame the media
you're guilty end of story you know I
know Jeffrey is in London has been in
London for the last few days and he
probably has not read the latest news
where BuzzFeed very liberal institution
debunk The Wall Street Journal story in
its entirety there was a course there
was a test it was fake and dr. Carson
was in that class and also a buzz he
didn't anybody but Yeldon I didn't know
and let me go tonight we finished a
medic and also with the issue with Yale
that was also debunked as well as the
belt buckle his mother had an interview
with Parade magazine in 1995 NBC pulled
it up and she said without a doubt he's
tried to stab someone in the belt buckle
stop that she had a talk with him and it
changed a lot but what I want to say
here
you know I respect my brother here and I
respect mr. Allister but you know what
times change sometimes the great names
the bushes and the Clintons Americans
don't want dynasties I can't tell you
what's wrong with America today I agree
with but there's a reason why no matter
what happens during the debate no matter
what dr. Carson and mr. Trump may say
they rise in the polls they raise more
money and those that do well in the
debates will do well in the debate and
for a week or so but yet just like Carly
Fiorina they drop to the bottom rung in
Atlanta until someone shows us how these
candidates that you so favor is going to
merge and catch up with mr. Trump that
mr. Carson I tell you the more things
change the more they will remain saying
I and one of the lows in the wind so
much though because there is a volatile
is it because it's not about them
anymore their season has passed the
American people are into a new season
and a new mindset it doesn't matter how
eloquent mr. Rubio is it doesn't matter
how great the Bush family has what
they've contributed to the American
people it doesn't matter what he says
the American people not hearing it
they're not listening to him they've
made up their minds and it only grows a
month ago mr. Trump had cars about 18
percentage points in South Carolina
today mr. Carson leaves I can't explain
everything but I will tell you something
something is growing in the psyche and
in the hearts of the American people and
it's not establishment I disagree but he
may be on to something no he does a
ground swell of regular Americans trying
to like what these guys in Carson is
following in the ground swell of great
American names like michelle bachman
rick santorum rick perry and all the
other losers who rose for a minute had
their 15 minutes of fame and very
quickly retreated into the into the
obscurity they so richly deserve and I'm
going to say this I've never said this
before Ben Carson's the political fraud
he's an absolute political front why
well if you read Charles blows editorial
in the New York Times he sums it up
pretty well where he talks about the
Carson brand what he's doing is selling
the Carson brand he stopped his campaign
for a book tour to make money he's in
this for the big bucks he never in a
million years thought he would ever rise
up
the to the top of the the party for a
while well he will sit back down again
because he's embarrassing himself a
stupid stupid comments and he went as
soon as he realizes he's ruining the
brand he'll drop out not many and I are
you there many Americans will criticize
a guy for making money no I'm not
creation and I'm liking him for being a
political fraud and I and I'm very firm
on that so that would make all of them a
political fraud most for tomorrow okay
including Hillary know Hillary Hillary
Hill she's a knee over Hillary is
absolutely is comical Hillary's
absolutely qualified to be president
Carson Oh is she of political fraud
hundred I'm not talking with the money
oh that's how you been ki just want
above why he stopped his campaign that's
a simple question I'm am Carthoris does
that include mrs. Clinton no it does not
include you as qualified why do you
explain to us why you think it does
include mrs. Clinton the Clinton
Foundation being influence of secretary
of state where the government the money
in Haiti that was to go to clean up and
make people's lives better it's worth
stuffing it ever has been the email a
list hello I'm not here to talk about
Miss cook but I will tell you this can't
you tell by my brother's facial
expression Carson frightens these people
no I'm are you afraid no kids I would
swim person money I would send him money
because I want him to be the candidate
cuz ben Carson will lose 75 states and
there are only 50 the good news Orson
will destroy the Republican Party well
they can't say what the way gold what it
did is easy for you I wish you'd also
get ready for the destruction I wish it
ready for listen Ben Carson okay not
gonna build hey when he wins the White
House it'll be okay oh he country would
be ye wow you would you be okay we ain't
gonna hire an ammeter trigger it'll be
on a forum I just want you to know to be
a country can't afford you through it
you gotta be your therapist I'm gonna
have to because I'll move in here k well
usually this is a long long race the
marathon isn't it we've just about less
than a year to go now to get the
nominations done and then the general
all starts and everything else between
the two candidates that emerge it's
exhausting isn't it for the candidate
and I'm wondering isn't exhausting for
the electorate don't they however much
they might like the rhetoric of a trump
they've never gotten do they not get
tired over here
more exciting GOP presidential cycle in
ages it's entertaining it's thrilling
it's the best reality will push for was
the best reality show gone on in America
right now and the candidates that's a
risk though I'm strong isn't it's just a
reality show it doesn't really matter
although Trump listen debates in and of
themselves is reality TV it's Thea it's
a performance that's what they are it's
a beauty pageant they parade them across
they say good things they look good in a
nice ties in a nice dress there's a
beauty contest but when they're out in
the land among the grassroots
campaigning that's where it really
matters it doesn't matter what you see
on TV what matters is how they connect
to the voters and then further their
brand with the voters that were in that
voted for them and these primaries and
ultimately throughout the country you
understand all the polls or republican
possible voters and ben Carson does have
an attachment to the evangelical voter
as soon as that dries up he's got nobody
he can't win New York he can't win
California he won't win Florida won't
win Ohio you know you lose those four
states you can't be President but he
won't get the nomination pays the
Republicans will not commit suicide like
Haitian they won't allow it Donald work
has got enough money to perhaps by his
way in but you watch Rubio Cruz I mean
I'd love to see Cruz he would do as much
damage to the Republicans as ben Carson
would it's Rubio and I do like cases
because cases could be President he
talks sense but because he talks sense
he won't get the remote just to the
interest of balance here there's still
some doubts about mrs. Clinton's
electability yes no I don't know yes of
course I don't know you can't see
opinion polls in and in in the you know
the the professional political class do
worry about all the baggage she's gonna
bring to this what package there you go
the email scandal was proven to be
nothing Benghazi the Republicans have
wasted trillions of dollars on Benghazi
and come up with nothing she's former
Secretary of State former first lady
former senators she's got all the
qualifications and as Alistair said
she's lost so she knows now knows how to
win I mean look at Bernie Sanders now I
interviewed Bernie Sanders years ago and
I found him to be an angry old man
Bernie Sanders the other night with
Rachel Maddow on MSNBC and the long
interview with him turned out to be
charming funny and he talks sense
he does make sense now will he have a
chance to to to become president I doubt
it but he talks good sense none of the
Republicans make any sense whatsoever
you see we it'll be a different time
frame but we have in the UK here the
reality of testing out this theory
because we have a popular candidate who
does not appear to be the identical
politician in Jeremy Corbyn who is now
the leader of the Labour Party right so
in a very similar way different
political perspective but in a very
similar way he's a popular uprising but
in the most of the commentariat are
saying he doesn't stand a hope in hell
and yet in a few years time when we go
to the polls he might just win well so
this idea that the outsider who has a
career politician to correspond energy
for an indenture without getting at the
inside baseball what happens in a few
years is he runs against Boris Johnson
who's now the mayor of london and Boris
Johnson sweeps the election completely
enjoys your prediction is a lot but yeah
I just want to make sure I just want to
make sure because i love when Jeffrey
makes these declarations I just love it
I am not as confident to make
declarations about what would happen
between here in November 2060 but I pray
that you live that you and I are in the
set together right after the election
when ben Carson is president of the
united states and not Hillary Clinton
it'll actually finally it'll have to be
in England believe in the country
whatever that's different that you
finally show humility and show that you
can be wrong I'll bring the cake okay
and on how to count this on yeah you got
eat it okay that thought guys great to
have you with us and thank you very much
any his brother my brother Zinedine Ian
I get it that's it for this edition of
the debate you can continue watching sky
news on Apple TV Roku and catch up and
of course at Sky News calm until next
time goodbye
you
you